[Music]
no matter who you are high school is the
same it's the best of times it's the
worst of times full of wonderful people
and not so wonderful people high school
kind of sucked for us we know that there
has been some bad blood between us but
there is no reason why we can't finish
off the school year being civil Wow
while fifteen crushed your enemy totally
so we're screwed
we are gonna stand up for ourselves how
exactly are we gonna do that
all we had to do was convince the
outsiders misfits and weirdos at the
school to band together where you're
proposing is like the Rebel Alliance why
do we have to sci-fi nerds here he's
sci-fi I'm fantasy is totally different
neither of you get laid right yes
these files represent the entire student
body
is figuring out what makes people tick
and exploiting it mercilessly I like you
Virginia even if you are named after a
slave state let's do this you're gonna
be popular we're actually thinking more
along the lines of revenge
smells like conch on here anyway and it
blew it up I will not allow that roam
the halls of the school thinking that
they were my equal
man rich white people are messed up
thank you for hosting us
my mom says never come to a party
empty-handed oh my god
we are diversify our high school
experiences already wimpy
are you kidding there's one thing I
learned from my years of video kid that
you have zero control of your own life